ich bin gespannt auf unser nächstes
treffen
bis jetzt läuft es doch sehr gut aber es
gibt noch sehr viel zu tun
ihr habt beide recht ganz sicher na dann
auch weiterhin gute kooperation
danke alex wir telefonieren fährst jetzt
direkt zurück nach baum nein
falls du heute abend noch nichts vor
habt es gibt eine vernissage in köln
vielleicht habt ihr lust zu kommen
galerie meier und fing ich hätte große
lust darauf aber ich habe einen termin
tut mir leid da kann man nichts machen
ich muss noch sehen wie weit ich mit
unserem konzept komme aber vielleicht ok
schickt mir das überarbeitete konzept
ich muss los
unsere arbeit
wie süß vielleicht solltest du besser
nicht hingehen sex mit dem ex lexmark
ist unser kunde
aja kunde gästen
deine idee zweitens mag und ich wir
haben uns nicht getrennt weil wir uns
nicht mehr verstehen unsere
lebensauffassung wagen komplett
unterschiedlich und drittens ich bin in
einer glücklichen beziehung als ich dir
auch wünsche
waren unterschiedlich vergangenheit
was du nicht siehst du mit ihm bin ich
richtig weiß und hh muss mit der zeit
gehen
coffee to go ist natürlich sehr passend
aber nicht besonders innovativ aber es
ist ein anfang
klingt sehr nach nora entwickeln
gemeinsam ideen
es war ihr vorschlag den schon von
unserem wettbewerb erzählt ich habe
richtig machte zu milchkaffee sojamilch
laktosefreier milch oder normale mich
bitte kommt sofort
ich weiß
das wieder richtig
juli
ich mag
hast du mal moment gekommen
alex hat brückmann vier bands
vorgeschlagen man sehen auch wenn man es
am ende einigen bisschen komisch der
typ- oder ich bin gerade dabei das team
für den dreh zusammen zu stellen was dem
fotografen betrifft hat max agentur
einen vorschlag gemacht womit die person
dann gesetzt ist oder ich denke ich auch
dass ich noch fragen wollte hast du
einen vorschlag in sachen homebase also
der ort wo wir kostüm maske und catering
unterbringen können wenn ich mir die
mögliche motive so ansehe haben wir dort
nicht viel platz und brauchen eine
zentrale ich hätte da vielleicht eine
idee die letzten klassen stehen und
sechs woche als abgabetermin für massa
du darfst es einen tapetenwechsel kann
ich ja da habt ihr euch gestritten
laut dabei gestern morgen bei uns wirkt
nicht sehr glücklich heute weiß
heute zählt er davon noch nicht belegt
sie nach strich und faden
diese ich weiß nicht wer super ganz toll
wenn ich wohl der einzige mit dem sie
nicht redet revolte grund wie lange ist
ihr schon alt lotter schwanger ist